Lisa Marie Presley is opening up about
her experience with grief two years
after her son Benjamin Keough died by
Suicide at 27 years old Lisa Marie is
sharing an essay published by people in
honor of national grief Awareness Day
Lisa Marie's goal to help others who can
relate she laments I can understand why
people may want to avoid you once a
terrible tragedy has struck especially
apparent losing their child because it
is truly your worst nightmare
Lisa Marie explains since Benjamin's
death in 2020 it's been a battle of
beating myself up tirelessly and blaming
myself every single day she writes that
it's especially tough to cope with while
also facing judgment from others people
can feel that you know the singer
recalls being on the flip side of the
situation when she came across parents
who'd lost their children she says she
did the exact same thing avoided them
and never bothered to check on them
because they represented her biggest
fear Lisa Marie admits she low-key
judged them and swore she'd take action
as a parent herself to escape ever
having to experience losing a child well
I didn't know any different Lisa Marie
addresses losing several of her loved
ones as she puts it she's felt more than
anyone's fair share of grief after death
starting with the death of her dad Elvis
Presley when she was only nine he was a
very special person and everybody loved
him he's still alive in all of us and
we're carrying on on for him in the
essay she notes how Benjamin reminded
her of her dad on so many levels that he
actually scared me I'll just say you're
killing me right now you're killing me
right now and then he'll be what so I
don't know it just it depends sometimes
some certain uh the way he talks the way
he moves himself also the way it looks
but just his mannerisms are also very
similar Lisa Marie urges readers to
understand that grief doesn't diminish
over time and having a great support
system is important and that support she
gets from her three daughters actress
Riley Keough and 13 year old twins
Finley and Harper Lockwood
[Music]
Elvis biopic I'm gonna show you what the
real Elvis is like tonight
[Applause]
the trouble
I came to the right place the movie is
important the subject matter is
important the story is that it tells
this is obviously a huge honor to me and
my family and
um and my children Lisa Marie
specifically Praises Austin Butler's
portrayal of her father a performance
she calls nothing short of spectacular
there's a responsibility to his family
and also putting his story into context
like that was a big thing there's so
many misconceptions about him there's so
many ideas of him so I felt such a
responsibility to bring the humanity at
the time of its release Lisa Marie said
it breaks my heart that Benjamin isn't
here to see it but he would have
absolutely loved it
foreign